hey what's up guys it's Robin welcome to
my tutorial for the 3d secret heart
locket the 3d secret heart locket is a
beautiful gift whether you want to catch
the attention of that special someone or
even give someone a present you'll need
some paper whether you want to use
origami paper or printer paper and if
you do want to make the locket then
you're going to need it some string
about 30 to 36 inches of whatever kind
of string you want should work fine I
did get some really awesome comments on
my mini fireworks tutorial that I did
right here and be sure to check that out
and the end of the tutorial to see if
you were featured if you do like this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
down below and also subscribe and click
that notification bell so once you have
all the supplies let's get started as a
general rule the size of the 3d secret
heart locket will be about half the size
of the starting sheet so if you use 6 to
7 inch origami paper or eight and a half
by eleven letter size your heart
dimensions will be about three to four
inches respectively I found it a bit
easier to learn with the larger paper so
I'll be using the eight-and-a-half by
eleven colored paper for this tutorial
I'll explain how you can make a smaller
sheet and also how to start with other
paper types taking the upper right
corner I'm going to align the top edge
with the left side and make a little
crease on the bottom right
I'm going to make a mark there and you
can also draw a line and cut it or flip
it over fold it down to that mark make a
nice crease and tear the paper this
makes an 8 and a half inch square sheet
to make this smaller locket will first
take the paper fold it in half and then
crease it and tear it will also do the
same thing as before by taking it making
the mark creasing it and then tearing
the paper this makes a five and a half
inch square now that we have the size
square sheet that we want just be aware
that the sides that we start with facing
up is going to be on the inside of the
heart knowing that we could then take
the top edge and fold it down to the
bottom edge once it's neatly aligned
then we can make a crease along the top
of the paper and I like to make nice
sharp creases by just running my
fingernail against it
then once we open it up will now have a
horizontal crease I'm just going to turn
it like this 90 degrees so that
this crease is vertical then I'm going
to take the top edge and once again fold
it down to the bottom just like that
once it's neatly aligned I'm just going
to hold it there and I'm just going to
walk my finger up and I'm just going to
press right on the top now we can open
it up and you'll see that we have a
little dimple in the paper I'm just
going to make a mark so that you could
see a little easier once you have that
little mark in the paper then we could
take the top edge and fold it down
directly on that mark and once again
just make a nice sharp crease along the
top we're going to also take the bottom
edge and fold it on that mark as well so
line the bottom edge up with the middle
and crease now we can unfold the top
edge of the paper and we're just going
to take it and fold it all the way to
the bottom and align the vertical line
then just like before we can walk our
finger up the vertical line and make a
dimple as you see here in the paper then
we can unfold the bottom and fold the
top down to the middle and do the same
with the bottom edge also walking our
finger down and making it Dipple on the
bottom once you unfold everything you'll
see that we made these two extra lines
that I'm just going to draw on then we
could just reclose the edges into the
middle and flatten it out now I'm going
to airplane fold this corner so that the
edge here on the outside is right on the
middle just take it fold it in and make
a crease on that corner and of course I
like to make it nice and sharp by
running my fingernail against the edge
then we could do the same with the
remaining three corners by folding them
in just like that and creasing on the
outside now we could just take the
corners unfold them all and flatten
everything out we're going to take these
corners once again and fold them
directly onto the new crease we just
made as you'll see here so just take the
corner round it off a little bit and
make sure that that edge is directly on
the new crease then just flatten it out
crease it really sharp and do the same
with the remaining three corners so just
neatly fold those corners in so that the
edges are directly on the crease then
you can unfold everything flatten it out
and we're just going to take the left
side and fold it down to the right side
you'll see these three dimples that we
made from before I'm just going to mark
them on the outside here so you can see
them as well then
you take the right corner and align the
top edge with that first vertical dimple
on the right just like this once it's
lined up nicely with that dimple then
just crease sharply on the outside and
we'll do the same on the left so just
round it off and crease it so that the
edge is right on that vertical dimple on
the left and crease it on the outside
sharply so you should have a paper that
looks just like this now we're going to
take the top edge and right where this
Center dimple is we're going to align it
with the corner right here and this edge
of the paper so we could just grab the
top edge of the paper here and round it
off and you can use your right thumb
right here on the corner as a pivot
point so you could just pull downwards
on the edge and match the two edges up
just like that then you're going to
basically just hold it there and just
pinch on this new crease right here and
we're just going to do it up to this
dimple you'll see here on the line right
to the middle just up to that point is
where we're going to crease it so just
run your fingernail against it
then you could open it up and we're
going to do the same on the left side
just taking this top edge matching it up
with the left corner edge and creasing
just onto the bottom of that triangle so
now that it looks like this we're just
going to take the two edges and close
everything just like a book and crease
along the top of this point this
triangle on top just like this now we're
not going to crease on this edge here
we're just going to leave it the way it
is it's okay if it has a little bit of a
dimple we're gonna unfold everything and
we're also going to unfold these corners
now we're going to fold backwards on
these corners on the same crease that
they have already in the paper flip it
to the other side and do the same exact
thing take the top edge in the middle
and meet it up with the corner edge just
to the bottom of that Center dimple do
the same with the left side and also
take the two edges like before and meet
them together like a book and crease
along the top of the point now we can
open the edges back up unfold the
corners and flatten it out and your
paper should look like this just like
before we're gonna take this outside
edge and corner and fold it directly
onto the new crease by rounding it off
and making a nice sharp fold do the same
on the left side and in the paper it's a
little thick here but
just work with it I know it's small and
then once it's lined up make that crease
then you can unfold it and we're going
to open everything up now on these
creases that we just made we're just
gonna tuck this in and fold on those
creases by just pinching on them and
doing a same on the left side on this
edge just fold on those creases and just
give it a good pinch then we're going to
open up this right side here this edge
and we're going to inside reverse fold
this corner so just open it up push down
on this corner so it's on the inside
flatten it out so that you have this
little flap here as you'll see then we
could do the same with the left side so
the same just open up the left edge tuck
this corner into the middle and flatten
it out so that you see that we have
these flaps here on the front we're
going to open up the right side edge
like this and you'll see we have a
crease on the corner here that we tucked
in we're going to fold this corner up on
that crease like this and just give it a
good pinch and then we could reclose
this edge back down and give it a good
crease on the outside and what that does
is it locks this flap down to the paper
we're going to do the same on the left
side opening up the left edge you were
going to take the corner and fold it
upwards on that crease and reclose the
edge back down and flatten everything
out so you should have a paper that
looks just like this now we could flip
the paper over and you'll see we have
this diamond in the middle and I'll draw
on it so you could make it out a little
easier we're going to crease downwards
or make Mountain folds on all four of
these edges of the diamond so from here
to here I'm just going to pinch
downwards on it and just run my
fingernail against it so do the same
from here to here just fold it down and
run your fingernail against it and the
same on the left side on these two just
fold down and crease and fold it down
and give it a good crease now we could
flip it over and we're just going to
pinch on the diamond only just like this
vertically still working on the inside
we're going to round it off by just kind
of giving it a curve in this direction
like this then I'm going to take the top
fold it down to the bottom and
push on the top in the center of the
diamond so it pops downwards and forms
an indentation squeezing the corners
here I'm going to push them together
like that and I'm just going to make
sure that everything is kind of folded
out and round it off on both sides so it
should look like this I'm going to open
up the two edges on the right and inside
reverse fold it like that do the same on
the left side open it up and just push
on the corner and as you'll see it got a
little bit stuck and crumpled I'm just
going to open it and pull downwards on
the corner and then just give it a pinch
just like before how we created a lock
on these inside reverse folds on these
flaps we're going to do the same on
these ones on the inside of the heart to
do that we're just going to hold it
closed and we already have existing
creases on here it gets a little tricky
here but just make sure that this inside
reverse fold is kind of flattened out so
you can just give it a pinch like this
and it has existing creases that you can
just fold it downwards on this just like
that you can also work from the side
through this side opening just like that
you can just kind of pinch it down and
give it a good squeeze doing the same on
the left side we're just going to close
these two edges together like this and
we're going to take the inside reverse
fold and we're going to create a lock on
it like that and pinch it now if the
model starts to get a little bit popped
in you could just round it off on the
inside like that and we're going to fold
upwards on the bottom right corner like
this on the existing crease and do the
same on the left side now you'll see on
the right we have a little pocket in
between these two flaps we're going to
round off this bottom right corner and
we're going to slide the corner right
into that existing pocket then you could
just squeeze it and we're going to do
the same on the left side round it off
and slide it in if you can't get it in
just open up the pocket a little bit by
sliding your finger into it and opening
it and then you could round it off and
slide that corner right into the
existing pocket like that and once
you're finished then just give it a nice
crease on both sides just like that and
if you see any parts that are popped in
just put your finger through the side
here and pop it out
and you can also just give it a squeeze
on the sides here like this and make
sure it looks really good all around and
there you go there's your 3d secret
heart locket if you make a smaller heart
and you want to make a locket out of it
then you could just take a piece of
string about 30 to 36 inches and all you
need to do so just take both ends and
just overlap them a bit like this take
one end and just wrap it around the
other and just form a knot out of it
just tie that and then do the same with
the other end tie it around and make a
knot and then as you'll see once you've
tightened everything you should be able
to adjust it by pulling on the knots
slide it into the inside of the heart
and put your little note or whatever you
want to put on the inside of it then you
can just close it back up and there you
go you have your 3d secret heart locket
with an adjustable necklace thank you
guys so much for watching the video I do
hope that you found it enjoyable and
whoever you give this to you're
definitely gonna score some points there
were a lot of awesome comments on the
last video a lot of funny comments a lot
of comments that really were inspiring
so thank you guys so much for the
support if you didn't see the lunar
eclipse last month there were some great
pictures that I posted on my Instagram
and you can also check out some of my
other social media accounts down in the
links below I have some ideas for some
new tutorials I will post a poll or
something else either in this video or
on my community tab but I'm definitely
excited about this year and releasing
some new stuff thanks again for watching
and I'll see you next time